guten morgen aus berlin und herzlich
willkommen zum ersten block seit langer
langer zeit
heute steht etwas großes an und zwar ist
heute abend das amazon fc st
event oder so aber dafür werde ich nicht
bezahlt ich gehe da nur hin weil luca
auch hingeht und wir uns da zusammen
besser die zeit vertreiben werden
jetzt geht es für mich aber erst mal ins
büro ist 15 ein bisschen spät dran also
erstmal in ordentlichen arbeitstag
reinbringen und danach zu diesem event
mit luka treffen und ich noch mit
stunden später soll ein kleines update
ich hab's ganz vergessen gerade eben hat
mich eh von dicken buch beim netzwerk
angerufen
sie hat mich angerufen hat gemeint ja im
zehn minuten treffen wir uns ist so hell
wie dem treffen das ist er los und dann
fiel mir ein dass ich heute ein
radiointerview bei energy hat mir
erzählt also heute ist echt vor das
programm so wie sie jetzt am potsdamer
platz und scheinbar ist das studio von
energy irgendwo da oben
so leute uns schon sehr im studio hier
glaub ich stehen oder an diesem ich
glaube da rechts und den filmen
radiointerview durch nach dem interview
geht wieder zurück dann die zweite
hälfte des arbeitstages
sohle des interviews rum und da habe ich
das interview führten text kommt heute
schon seine nur richtig 15 1 und 5 ihr
motto schock so der arbeitstag ist bis
jetzt hier auf einer veranstaltung zwar
auf
die unter anderem
leute zur neuen folge sie mit mir wohnt
ac dc
trotzdem sagen und eine
vielleicht deshalb so sehr dauert sagte
mir er sichtlich angeschlagen
aber irgendwie denke ich müssen was hier
alles eigentlich hast
carius
er ist dann auch